let's start with some very important
actually good news today at least sort
of if the problem gets fixed a judge has
ruled that ron desantis's new
redistricting map in the state of
florida is completely unconstitutional
not okay the lines are going to have to
be redrawn and this is very good news
because what was done in florida was
such a brazen attempt to gerrymander to
the benefit of republicans and everybody
tries to do it whenever they get the
opportunity they try to do it there's no
doubt
but this was so obvious and so brazen
that we were if this wasn't stopped by a
judge
then all bets are off so we have a very
good report from axios florida judge
says desantis redistrict redistricting
map unconstitutional
a florida judge on wednesday struck down
a portion of a redistricting map drawn
by florida governor ron desantis and his
staff
a leon county circuit judge lane smith
said i am finding that the enacted map
is unconstitutional under the fair
district amendment because it diminishes
african-americans ability to elect the
representatives of their choice a formal
order is expected today or tomorrow to
ensure the maps aren't used in november
this is a key part which is not only was
this map found to be unconstitutional
it can't be allowed to be used in
november while a new map is figured out
that's an absolutely critical element to
this
desantis's plan dismantles the north
florida seat now held by a black
democrat
the new maps desantis called race
neutral
make it harder for north florida voters
to elect a black member of congress in
the fifth congressional district where
nearly half its residents are black so
the technique that's used here is if you
have for example in this case a district
where you have a black democrat and
nearly half the residents are black and
you say well this is this is a seat that
as currently drawn is likely to be won
again by this uh elected official what
you do is you split that district up
and you put some of the black folks in
one republican district and some of the
black folks in another so that in
neither district do they have a critical
mass and in this way you can take one or
two seats and in fact when we look at
the map the whole point of the map as
drawn is to create a whole bunch a whole
bunch of rep easy republican districts
while making it very difficult for
democrats to win and of course as if
you're looking at this map you will see
that in southeastern florida the miami
etc area you have a number of blue
districts but these are maps that make
it very difficult for democrats to win
anywhere else and part of the way that
this is done
is by using general demographic trends
black folks tend to vote more for
democrats than republicans in florida
and you can you can use that to your
advantage
um
a democratic aligned redistricting group
joined voting rights and civil rights
organizations to file suit against this
map the same day it was signed into law
late last month and fortunately because
this doesn't always happen
it was adjudicated or evaluated
relatively quickly by the judge so
listen
nobody's surprised right i mean this is
this is not only the expected outcome of
ron desantis deciding he was going to
redistrict and draw the maps himself
this is this is a feature not a bug of
what they do here and the most important
things here number one that the judge
ruled on this quickly
but number two that the judges expected
today or tomorrow maybe by the time you
see this clip it will already have been
done
not allow these maps to be used in
november and
uh one of the
other aspects of this
is there is a sort of i don't want to
necessarily call it virtue signaling but
it's a sort of virtue signaling where
many things that ron desantis has done
have not been designed to stand up to
legal scrutiny in fact they were
probably done knowing they wouldn't
stand up to legal scrutiny the point
here is
to attempt a whole bunch of stuff
to then be able to use it either in his
reelection campaign which is getting
going now desantis is up for re-election
in november as governor of florida
or it's theorized and the polling
suggests that he may have a shot it's
theorized that ron desantis may try to
run for president of
starting with republican nominee in 2024
and so
you know opening florida early to large
sporting events when everything else was
shut down as we were trying to figure
out in 2020 what is covid how does it
work how contagious is it all of these
things he can use that
the don't say gay bill
the event to commemorate the victims of
communism i think it was called which we
talked about earlier this week obviously
unconstitutional congressional maps a
lot of this stuff isn't designed to
stand up to legal scrutiny because it's
not going to but it is designed to allow
ron desantis to take credit for it at
some point later and it wouldn't be i
would be shocked if he didn't do it
either
for his gubernatorial re-election
campaign or if he does decide to run for
president in um in 2024 now just as an
update we've been very very closely
following
um
what are the
uh what what are the betting odds when
it comes to the 2024
republican nominee and i actually am
trying to find it i don't have it in
front of me
uh where was this ah here it is
ron desantis
continues continues to close in on
donald trump and if we look now at last
check
um ron desantis was
roughly at 31 cents now it's 32 cents so
the whole point here is
you now have to wager 32 cents
to win a dollar on ron desantis being
the nominee meaning that the higher that
number goes the more likely it is that
desantis will be the nominee this is the
closest it has been
between trump and desantis for as long
as we've been tracking these numbers and
at one point desantis was down at like
11 or 12 and now up to 32.
he has almost caught up to donald trump
in terms of the betting odds we could
also look at uh actual polling it's just
not super accurate this far out
necessarily and sometimes looking at
betting betting odds gives you a little
more information so that's the latest
with desantis and we're going to
continue to follow it
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar that's why
you should check out our longtime
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon tastes
exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman